INTERVIEWER 1: Unknown
to the rest of the world,
there is a violent turf
war happening in Chile.
To truly understand it,
you have to go all the way
back to the 1500s, to the
start of the Arauca War.
When colonial Spaniards
began to try and take
control of Araucania, a
region about 450 miles south
of Santiago, then occupied by
numerous indigenous peoples,
including the Mapuche.
It was a land battle that
lasted for over 280 years,
and in the end, the
Chilean military
succeeded in taking Araucania.
SUBJECT 2: And then
the government,
after occupying
these places, they
started to open up
offices in Europe,
so they could bring settlers
to this part of Chile.
They would give away land,
so these people from Germany,
from Switzerland, came,
and they were given
territory, free territory.
All of this led to the
situation that we have now.
INTERVIEWER 1: This is Nicolas
Rios, a Chilean journalist
covering the Mapuche story,
who I met up with in Santiago.
He told me that around
600,000 Mapuche still live
in the forested
region of Araucania,
alongside small landowners
who are descendants
of European settlers.
But since the 1980s,
commercial logging companies
have also moved into the area.
And today, forestry is
Chile's second largest export,
supplying wood to countries
like Argentina, Japan,
and the United States.
However, in the
process of growth,
the industry has wiped away
much of the native forest
that the Mapuche call home.
SUBJECT 2: On one hand,
you have the Mapuches
claiming, or reclaiming,
the property of this land.
And on the other hand,
you have relatives
of those European settlers.
All these people claiming
property of the land,
so that's when the
clashes started to happen.
INTERVIEWER 1: Clashes
that turned more violent
after General Pinochet
seceded power in 1990.
SUBJECT 2: Before 1990,
there was a very strong hand
dictatorship here in Chile.
So nobody, really
nobody in the country
was able to form an organization
to fight for something.
INTERVIEWER 1: It was clear
after meeting Nicholas
that if I was really going to
understand what was going on,
I had to travel to Araucania.
Even though this
town's so small,
I see an armored vehicle
on every one of the corners
around.
It turns out that state
armored vehicles are actually
pretty common around here.
In the early 2000s,
the Chilean government
implemented a Pinochet
era anti-terrorist law.
A move that's been criticized
as an effort to strong arm
Mapuche into ceasing
their protests.
According to a UN report,
the Chilean police
were guilty of quote "A
systemic use of excessive force"
with reputed accounts
of brutality,
raiding homes, and detaining
Mapuche without charge.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERVIEWER 1: The Chilean
government has, in fact,
promised to buy back
and transfer the land
titles to the Mapuche.
However, according to
reports, these reparations
have been offered piecemeal and
are at an incredibly slow rate,
which is why many have taken
the law into their own hands.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERVIEWER 1: In the nearby
community of [INAUDIBLE],
that's exactly what happened.
Here, Mapuche have
started building illegally
in an attempt to lay claim
to their ancestral land.
But as we found out, this
strategy can backfire.
When we met this
Mapuche woman she
told us how the police
evicted her from land
that she'd built on illegally.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERVIEWER 1: We just visited
a house that was burned down.
It feels kind of like
the Wild West out here.
You get the sense that these
kinds of land rights issues
are really up to the people
who have the most money.
While in [INAUDIBLE], we
couldn't ignore the fact
that the Mapuche aren't the
only victims in this conflict.
Small landowners, like Sonia
Villobos, also live in fear.
As a descendant of
European settlers
who's been here for
generations, she
is distressed that some
Mapuche have threatened
to take her land away.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERVIEWER 1: It was an
interesting experience spending
a day with both a Chilean family
as well as a Mapuche family,
both who claim to have rights
to the same piece of land.
It's difficult to see how
this conflict is going
to be resolved, and
ultimately, it's
just a microcosm for land rights
issues between the Mapuche
people and the government
that had existed
for the past few hundred years.
SUBJECT 2: They are all victims,
the settlers are victims,
the Mapuche are victims, and
small farmers are victims.
They are all victims
here because of what
the state of Chile
did 120 years ago.
This is a situation
that has to be handled,
that needs a solution.
And I think that, if it
doesn't get a solution,
things could escalate
into a worse scenario
than we have now.
INTERVIEWER 1: Don't forget
to subscribe for more Seeker
stories, and be sure to check
out this next episode, where
I investigate the
unexpected reason
why wild pigs are
being hunted in Hawaii,
in order to conserve
coral reefs.